the expanse could still return but not
with Amazon not anything with HBO with a
completely different unexpected
streaming service
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
in the last video I did I talked about
how Apple tried to buy Stargate they
even tried to buy Star Trek and are
still trying to it's a hell of a break
and a golden opportunity or at least
produce a Star Trek series of their own
in cooperation with Paramount which is
not really the same as saying they're
buying Star Trek but a buying Star Trek
says far more dramatic doesn't it but
the reason why Apple are looking at
Stargate and Star Trek is because they
desperately want a big sci-fi franchise
for the apple plus streaming service and
being the most valuable company on the
planet they can really afford to put
their dollars where their mouth is and
produce something quite amazing but why
am I talking about this this video is
about the expanse well apparently
according to a couple of sources I speak
to they are actually looking to
potentially take the expanse from Amazon
and maybe finish off the series I'm
saying maybe quite a lot there because
there are a few options but there is
actually something reasonably solid to
go with this rumor please like subscribe
and hit the Bell notification if you are
new to the channel so you don't miss any
of our new videos also if you really
want to support the channel consider
hitting the join button and you'll get
all of our Thursday videos 24 hours
before anybody else all of the links are
in the description Ty Frank now and
Shankar and Breck Eisner are the main
people behind the expanse Thai Frank
actually co-authored the novels that
then in the TV series was based off and
acted as one of the main producers for
the TV series now and Shankar was now
the long-standing rumor that these guys
have been planning to create their own
production company and looks like that
about to there's been several meetings
and this has been confirmed by a couple
of sources I speak to it's something
they've wanted to do for a long time it
seems to be that they're going to come
together and produce their own
production company and it's that
production company that then produce
something for apple plus
now what they then produce for apple
plus is very much up in the air but it
looks like it would be hopefully a big
sci-fi franchise for the new streaming
service now apparently they would love
and they would adore to be able to
finish the expanse we know now Shankar
has talked about this in several
interviews since this um basically the
project was canceled by Amazon he kept
saying this is not a cancellation we're
on Hiatus we'll be back don't you worry
well it looks like it is possible well
I've already told you previously that
actually Amazon don't intend really do
anything with the expanse they
considered it they looked at maybe doing
a Trilogy of movies to finish off the
book series they looked at maybe doing a
spin-off series
um something that would have much
smaller scope on much smaller budget
than what they've had done previously
with the expanse but all of those plans
have really been put on hold
all of the streaming services really
kind of struggling at the moment and
they're all having to really consider
what projects they want to move forward
with because there just isn't the
finances that were there two years ago
but the production company that actually
owns the rights to the expanse is a
company called Alcon now they're the
company that actually produced the
television show for sci-fi Network
Netflix here in the UK and and then
Amazon
they still own the production rights but
currently Amazon owned the distribution
rights which means alcant can't make any
expanse because
Amazon basically won't distributed it
for them so they'd be making it just to
sit there but the contract with Amazon
does include a get out clause for
alcohol I'm being told that basically if
Amazon don't do anything with the
expense within a certain set time
um my source believed that was two years
then
Alcon could actually sell the rights to
the expanse to somebody else or produce
the expanse which is more likely for
another streaming service
now that two years is already almost up
so very shortly Alcon could actually go
to another streaming service and offer
the expanse now I was told uh a year ago
now that actually HBO Max would be very
interested and they made it very clear
to Alcon that if Amazon didn't pick up
the rights to produce further expense
that they would now since then HBO has
gone into a bit of a mess obviously its
parent company Warner Brothers mentioned
one brother's Discovery the new CEO
zazleaf came in and just started cutting
everything there's been a massive Purge
of projects and to be honest I cannot
see them now taking on the expanse like
maybe a year ago they would have liked
to however according to my sources Apple
now have expressed interest and they
said they would so why does tan Frank
now Shankar and Breck Eisner need to
create a new production company well
previously the expanse was produced in
cooperation with penguin and Parker Mark
Ferguson Hawk host company that company
is hopefully going to be making Stargate
but it is 100 going to be producing a
new God of War TV series for Amazon so
they've probably got enough on their
plate as it is so it seems to be that Ty
Frank and friends are going to create a
new production company to replace
penguin and Parker that they'll be
working alongside Alcon and they could
potentially produce something for apple
plus
now if Amazon allowed them to have the
rights without too much of an argument
that could be the conclusion to the
expanse series the last three seasons
but there's actually also lots of other
novels around the expanse universe that
they could potentially explore
or and something I kind of hope they
could do something completely different
again Ty Frank is a very talented writer
so is Breck Eisner they've done some
amazing sci-fi projects in the past why
couldn't they just create something new
now I would love to see the end of the
expanse but I have to be pragmatic here
if I was an apple executive I'd be
saying do we really want a TV show that
started its life on the Sci-Fi Network
ended up on Amazon and is now coming to
us
don't we want to be sort of like the big
boys in the streaming thing and we've
really taken other people's scraps or do
we want something new that's our own for
me I would be saying let's do something
new or at very least doing a project
that is outside of what Amazon currently
owns the current expanse core books and
do something based on some of those
expanded universe novels now that I
think would be really exciting and
something I'd be very keen to see
so it looks like we're going to be
getting a new production company from
the guys that wrote and produced the
expanse and it looks like that
production company is going to be
working with apple plus let's just wait
and see what is it they actually produce
guys game for comments tell me exactly
what you think is this news that is very
intriguing please go and look at these
guys names go and look at their resumes
there's some very interesting projects
on there and I'm wondering if these guys
together could produce something very
interested in the future
I'd also love to know that if the
expanse did move to Apple Plus would you
subscribe to it is that a big enough TV
show for you that you would put up with
the cost of another streaming service
hit me yes or no in the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification because that will tell you
when all of our new videos out and
you'll miss nothing also please consider
hitting the join button because that
really supports the channel and
obviously you get our Thursday videos 24
hours before anybody else
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time foreign
[Music]